so I took some screen captures from the
Khan Academy exercise on correlation
coefficient intuition and we've given
they've given us some correlation
coefficient so we need to match them to
the various scatter plots on that
exercise this little interface where we
can drag these around in a table to
match them to the different scatter
plots and the point isn't to figure out
how exactly to calculate these we'll do
that in the future but really get an
intuition of what we are trying to
measure and the main idea is that
correlation coefficients are trying to
measure how well a linear model can
describe the relationship between two
variables so for example if I have fi
let me go let me do some coordinate axes
here so let's say that's one variable
say that's my Y variable and let's say
that is my X variable and so let's say
when X is low Y is low when X is a
little higher Y is a little higher when
X is a little bit higher Y is higher
when X is really high Y is even higher
this one a linear model would describe
it very very very well we can it's quite
easy to draw a line that goes through
that essentially goes through those
points so something like this would have
an R of 1 R is equal to 1 a linear model
perfectly describes it and it's a
positive correlation when one increases
when one variable gets larger than the
other variable is larger when what the
other one one variable is smaller than
the other variable is smaller and vice
versa
now what would an R of negative 1 look
like well that would once again be a
situation where linear model works
really well but when one variable moves
up the other one moves down and vice
versa so let me draw my coordinates my
coordinate axes again so I'm going to
try to draw a data set where the R would
be negative 1 so maybe when Y is high X
is very low when y becomes lower X
becomes higher when Y becomes good but
lower X becomes a good bit higher so
once again when Y when y decreases Y in
x increases or as x increases Y
decreases so they're moving in opposite
directions but you can fit a line very
easily to this
so the
mine would look something like look
something like this so this would have
an R of negative 1 and an R of 0 r is
equal to 0 would be a data set where
it's a line doesn't really fit very well
at all so I'll do that one really small
since I don't have much space here so an
R of 0 might look might look something
like this well maybe I have a data point
here maybe have a data point here maybe
have a data point here maybe have a data
point here maybe I have one there there
there there there and it wouldn't
necessarily be this well-organized but
this gives you a sense of thing where
would you actually how would you
actually try to fit a line here you
could equally justify a line that looks
like that or a line that looks like that
or a line that looks like or a line that
looks like that so there really isn't a
linear model really does not describe
the relationship between the two
variables that well right over here so
what that is a primer let's see if we
can tackle these scatter plots now the
way I'm going to do it is I'm just gonna
try to eyeball what a linear model might
look like and there's different methods
of trying to fit a linear model to a
data set and imperfect geddes that I
drew very perfect ones at least for the
R equals negative 1 and R equals 1 but
these are what the real world actually
looks like nothing very few times will
things perfectly sit on a line so for
scatter plot a if I were to try to fit a
line it would look something like it
would look something like that if I were
try to minimize distances from these
points to the line
I do see a general trend that when y is
you know if I look at these data points
over here when y is high X is low and
when X is high when X is larger Y is
smaller so it looks like R is going to
be less than zero in a reasonable bit
less than 0 it's going to approach this
thing here and if we look at our choices
so it wouldn't be R equals 0.65 these
are positive so I wouldn't use that one
or that one and this one is almost no
correlation R equals negative 0.02 this
is pretty close to zero so I feel good
with R is equal to negative 0.72 R is
equal to negative 0.72 now I want to be
clear if I didn't have these choices
here I wouldn't just be able to say just
looking at these data points without
being able to do a calculation that R is
equal to negative 0
seven - I'm just basing it on the
intuition that it is a negative
correlation it seems pretty strong a you
know you're the pattern kind of jumps
out at you that when Y is large Y X is
small when X is large y is small and so
I like something that's approaching R
equals negative one so I've used this
one up already now scatterplot B if I
were to just try to eyeball it once
again this is going to be imperfect but
the trend if I were to try to fit a line
it looks something like that
so it looks like a line fits it
reasonably well there's some points that
would still be hard to fit they're still
pretty far from the line and looks like
it's a positive correlation and when X
is small when Y is small X is relatively
small and vice versa and when X as X
grows Y grows and when Y grows X grows
so this one's going to be positive and
it looks like it would be reasonably
positive and I have two choices here so
I don't know which of these it's going
to be so it's either going to be R is
equal to 0.65 or R is equal to 0.8 for I
also get scatter plots see now this
one's all over the place it kind of
looks like what we did over here you
know I could you know I what does a line
look like you could almost imagine
anything does it look like that does it
look like that
does a line look like that these things
really aren't don't seem to there's not
a direction that you could say well as x
increases maybe Y increases or decreases
there's no rhyme or reason here so this
looks very non correlated and so this
one is pretty close to zero so I feel
pretty good that this is the R is equal
to negative point zero two in fact you
know if we tried probably the best line
that could be fit would be one with a
slight negative slope so it might look
something like this
it might look something like this and
notice even when we try to fit a line
there's all sorts of points that are way
off the line so the linear model did not
fit it that well so R is equal to
negative 0.02 so we use that one and so
now we have scatterplot D so that's
going to use one of the other positive
correlations and it does look like well
you know there is a positive correlation
when Y is low X is low and Y is when X
is high Y is I and vice versa and so we
could try to fit something that looks
something looks something like that but
it's still not as good as that one you
can see the points that we're trying to
fit there's several points that are
still pretty far away from
our our model so the model is not
fitting it that well so I would say
scatterplot B is a better fit a linear
model works better for scatterplot B
then it works for scatterplot D so I
would give the higher R to scatter plot
B and the lower R R equals 0.65 to
scatterplot D R is equal to 0.65 and
once again that's because with the
linear model it looks like there's a
trend but there's a several data points
that really more data points do not are
way off the line in scatterplot D than
in the case of scatterplot B there's a
few that are still way off the line but
these are even more off of the line in D